en agriculture : le manque de
relève. Au Canada, quatre fermes
sur cinq n'ont pas de relève
identifiée pour poursuivre
les opérations. Mais alors que
les embûches sont nombreuses,
on n'a qu'à penser au coût
des terres agricoles, certains
choisissent tout de même de
faire le grand saut. Alors,
qui sont ces jeunes agriculteurs
qui acceptent le défi de nous
nourrir et pourquoi décident-ils
de renouveler les générations?
♪ ♪ ♪
- (narratrice): Ceux et
celles appelés à renouveler
les générations en agriculture
arrivent un peu bousculés; par
les attentes des consommateurs,
les grands accords commerciaux,
les normes sanitaires ou la
protection de l'environnement.
Ils joignent les rangs
d'un groupe qui fait face
à d'énormes défis.
- On a confié la production
d'aliments, qui est une
responsabilité fondamentale,
une responsabilité
très importante, à moins
de 1 % de la population.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Mais les jeunes de la relève
ont voulu le métier, portés
par une grande passion.
- C'est impossible de choisir
ce métier-là si t'es pas
passionné, si t'es pas amoureux
de la production agricole.
C'est impossible, là.
C'est trop difficile.
- Depuis 2008 au Québec,
près du tiers des jeunes
agriculteurs sont des femmes.
Hommes et femmes s'installent de
plus en plus âgés et instruits :
82 % possèdent un diplôme
post-secondaire, et plus de la
moitié ont entre 35 et 39 ans.
La relève est mieux outillée,
mais une bonne part ne possédera
sans doute pas la ferme de ses
rêves; une question d'argent.
- Le plus grand obstacle, c'est
toujours l'accès à la ressource.
Et la première ressource,
c'est la terre de qualité.
La valeur du prix des terres
a connu une augmentation très
importante depuis 15 à 20 ans.
Alors, pour acquérir une
entreprise agricole, il faut
disposer d'un certain capital;
parce qu'une entreprise agricole
ne peut pas supporter
un endettement équivalent
à sa valeur marchande.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les plus avantagés -- 56 % --
sont ceux qui reprennent
la ferme familiale.
(meuglement)
Plus de la moitié de ces
entreprises font dans le lait,
les oeufs et la volaille.
Pour les autres qui n'ont pas
cette chance -- 9 % -- achètent
une ferme déjà en production,
mais d'une personne n'ayant
aucun lien familial. Ce type
de transfert est en baisse.
Et pour les autres, dans une
proportion toujours en hausse,
de 35 %, ils se lancent
en agriculture en démarrant
une toute nouvelle entreprise,
depuis les tout débuts.
- Je vous dirais qu'il y a
comme un appel naturel envers
la nature. Puis des fois,
ils ont une façon de voir
l'agriculture un peu différente
de nos jeunes qui viennent du
milieu agricole. Donc, ça aide
beaucoup les échanges qu'ils
ont, les étudiants, entre eux,
pour faire avancer justement
l'agriculture.
- Parmi tous les jeunes de la
relève, 35 % des jeunes, privés
de mise de fonds importante,
doivent louer leurs actifs.
♪ ♪ ♪
Les jeunes s'établissent
alors en régions périphériques
et organisent leur propre
mise en marché.
- Les produits nichés, les
produits de circuit court, c'est
une tendance; c'est une tendance
de fond. Et définitivement que
ça va continuer parce que le
consommateur aime les histoires
du terroir. Le consommateur
aime le.storytelling.  Et je sus
persuadé qu'il y a encore
énormément de potentiel.
- Bonjour. Je vais prendre trois
pots de beurre, s'il vous plaît.
- Bonjour. Oui, ça me fera
plaisir.
- Au Québec, comme au pays,
la production biologique
est plus populaire dans
les fermes ayant une relève.
Même élan pour la vente directe
aux consommateurs dans près
de 20 % des fermes au pays.
- Alors, est-ce que la relève
est prête? Oui. Est-ce qu'il
y a encore du potentiel de
développement, des opportunités,
des possibilités? Absolument.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Au Canada, depuis 2006, la
relève consacre moins d'heures
par semaine à travailler à la
ferme; en partie parce que près
de la moitié occupent un emploi
à l'extérieur, et aussi pour
vivre leur vie de famille.
- Ils vont s'accorder plus
de temps à eux autres, ce qui
va faire en sorte qu'ils vont
retrouver peut-être un peu plus
de bien-être dans ce métier-là.
Parce que c'est un métier
excessivement exigeant,
très exigeant.